parce qu'il ya toujours une situation
qui échappe aux explications de la
notice parce que douter sur le choix
d'une casse c'est se retrouver coincé
dans ce passage obligé
ou tout simplement pour être sûr
d'éviter la boulette les étudiants en
master 2 de droit fiscal étudie chaque
cas particulier c'est pas toujours
évident est les déclarations d'impôts il
ya des endroits où on sait pas ce qu'il
faut mettre les papiers qu'on reçoit ne
sont pas toujours explicites
ça me permet d'avoir des meilleures
informations puni d'éviter des erreurs
ou double emport beaucoup de questions
aussi sur la grande nouveauté fiscale de
l'année le prélèvement à la source
la déclaration reste obligatoire et elle
se fait de la même façon ou presque à la
fin de sa télédéclaration le pourcentage
du salaire qui sera prélevée est
indiquée un pourcentage global pour un
foyer qui sera appliqué à chaque
conjoint en cas de disparité importante
de salaire il y aura une alternative
vous pouvez également puisque les deux
taux seront précisés individualiser le
taux en fonction des revenus de chacun
et c'est à vous à ce moment là de faire
cette option est là dans ce cas là votre
entreprise ou votre caisse de retraite
appliquera donc ce taux personnaliser
les étudiants accueilleront le public
jusqu'au 17 mai ce sera avant minuit ce
jour là qu'il faudra rendre sa
déclaration papier délais plus longs
pour la télédéclaration le 29 mai en
côte d'or le 5 juin pour les autres
départements de bourgogne